hey this is presh talwalkar
simplify the following fraction
the numerator is the square root of the
quantity 10 plus the square root of 1
plus the square root of the quantity 10
plus the square root of 2
and so on
until we add the final term the square
root of the quantity 10 plus the square
root of 99
the denominator is the square root of 10
minus the square root of 1
plus the square root of the quantity 10
minus the square root of 2
and so on until we add the final term
the square root of the quantity 10 minus
the square root of 99
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this
[Music]
problem so how can we solve this problem
let's look for a pattern in the
numerator and the denominator
in the numerator we have the square root
of 10
plus the square root of 1
then we have the square root of 10 plus
the square root of 2
and so on until we have the square root
of 10 plus the square root of 99.
in the denominator we have a similar
pattern except each time we're
subtracting the square root
so we can write the numerator in general
terms
as a n
is equal to the sum from k equals 1 to n
squared minus 1
of the square root of n plus the square
root of k
in our particular problem n is equal to
10.
the denominator can be written as b n
which is the sum from k equals 1 to n
squared minus 1 of the square root of n
minus the square root of k
we are looking to simplify the ratio a n
over b n
so how can we do that
whenever there are nested square roots
it's a good idea to take the square of
the terms
so let's take
the square root of n plus the square
root of k
minus the square root of n minus the
square root of k
we'll take this difference and we'll
square it
we'll expand this binomial which gets
rid of some of the square roots
then
plus square root of k will cancel with
negative square root of k
we then have 2n and we have minus 2
times the square root of n squared minus
k
we can now take the square root of both
sides
so we have the square root of n plus the
square root of k minus the square root
of n minus the square root of k is equal
to the square root of 2 multiplied by
the square root of the quantity n minus
the square root of n squared minus k
from here let's take the sum of both
sides
for k equaling 1 to n squared minus 1.
let's focus on n squared minus k
when k goes from 1 to n squared minus 1.
if we evaluate this we'll see that the
terms will be n squared minus 1 n
squared minus 2 and it'll decrement all
the way to 1.
so this goes from 1 to n squared minus 1
in descending order
but we could similarly have a different
index where we just take k
if we just have k and it goes from k
equals 1 to k equals n squared minus 1
this will be exactly the same terms in
the reverse order
so we can substitute because we'll have
exactly the same terms when we have k
going from 1 to n squared minus 1.
so on the right hand side this summation
is equal to the sum
k equals 1 to n squared minus 1 of the
square root of 2
multiplied by the square root of n minus
the square root of k
now we can simplify this formula
tremendously
the left hand side is equal to a n minus
b n and the right hand side is equal to
b n multiplied by the square root of 2.
we have a simple linear equation
we'll add b n to both sides
then we'll factor b n on the right hand
side
and finally we'll divide both sides by b
n
so we get a n over b n is equal to the
square root of two plus one
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of bind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you